excited have back here in the program
Kelvin Sampson how are you coach I'm
doing great I'm better for talking to
you sir Congrats on the sweet 16 birth
sir Congrats on thank you you back south
part of this group of kids could be more
thrilled to then well certainly again
it's been a long time for the school but
these kids it doesn't really obviously
I'm sure it's difficult to for these
kids to even comprehend all that because
none of them were alive when all of that
stuff happened how do you keep these
kids on an even keel coach I think it
starts with our routine we don't change
our first game of the year was way back
in early November
I guess Alabama A&M our system coaches
do a great job as our preps
Scouts every game we've had everything
we do is a routine they know what to
expect when they walk in the gym two
days before the day before the day off
they know they know what they're gonna
get for me every day they know the
standards that we sent on a daily basis
and that has not changed since our first
game in season so I think by by having a
routine not changing now the world
around them changes people talk to them
different tell them things different but
we you know we're always one of the
things all coaches have to do now is
coach is coach again social media they
make sure they stay off of it as far as
hitting that send button keeping them
humble your coaching that the more
successful you become the more that
stuff comes into play yeah how do you
coach against social media I mean when
you say you keep him off it and you do
better in terms of them being bombastic
you know given the other teams bulletin
board material responding to things they
shouldn't respond to you can't stop
social media but you can keep them from
embarrassing the program and that's
usually what your responsibility is so
you have your comments about putting
some sort of money from a huge pot of
gold that the NCAA bathes in with this
tournament putting some aside for
parents or family members to attend
these games on the road because they
can't afford it
do you have members of Houston cougar
families sleeping on floors right now to
come watch these kids play over the last
weekend or expected for Thursday no no
no I do not have anybody sleeping on
floors but I've had but I've had mothers
that have asked me if they can get to
the game would it be alright if they
accept slept on their sons floor because
I can't can't afford a hotel room that's
reality so I think you know the
n-c-double-a tournament is such a
phenomenon in our country and I'm not
talking about the regular-season or
conference tournaments but you know most
most of the kids will be there for one
game and they'll be eliminated a lot of
these schools we certainly could have
been eliminated after one game and but
for that one moment you know we can we
talked about one shining moment and we
build up this tournament and they get
there and these parents all of a sudden
a lot of these parents a lot of these
kids come from one one parent families a
lot of them only have a mother and and
this particular mother she just touched
my heart that really touched my heart
and she asked me that question and it's
I don't remember how I came up in the
press conference that we had in Tulsa
but I'm I just wish there you know the
n-c-double-a to come a long way we
actually have we actually have a stipend
that we give each kid called a cost of
attendance check I think it's around
anywhere from three to five hundred
dollars depending on the school and and
that's great as tremendous that the
n-c-double-a did that so if we can do
that I don't know why we couldn't for
one time only just for the NC double-a
tournament I'm not talking about any
other time of the year because this is
such a cool event and not just
guys ladies too when you're when you're
painting your you get to the tournament
be able to fly your mom and dad mom or
dad brother and sister in for that for
that game just so they can experience it
with you there's nothing there's nothing
worse than having to be in a moment like
that creates the magic for yourself in
your team and have to call your parent
come about it did you watch it on TV mom
did you see me today when that when
maybe they could have been there if we
could have helped him
Kelvin Sampson Houston and coach here in
the Rich Eisen show I guess the you know
there's always the unintended
consequence to as to who would
constitute I'm trying to work this thing
out because you're right I mean this is
this is the as you point out
heartbreaking heart-wrenching et cetera
you know the the the Pandora's Box if
you will is who would constitute a
family member you know how do you make
sure that the money is actually used
towards something and all that the
actual family members of mother mm-hmm
right and I guess or if a legal guardian
or something like that so so what what
can you office I don't want to have name
any names what did you tell the mom I
mean how do you how do you break the
news to mom that she may not actually
pull out a couch or get a cot or sleep
on the floor no I mean there's obviously
rules against extra benefits and that
would that would come under that though
so we we couldn't we couldn't do it and
that's the only reason I didn't mean to
open Pandora's Box yeah it was more of
an emotional reaction well I mean you're
examine being your you're only talking
about here and human emotions right here
and you know and then obviously your
your thought process goes to I think I
saw were the television contract for the
tournament was nine hundred million if
I'm not mistaken close to a billion and
I you think about all the money that's
going to be made off this tournament in
the primary
the primary entity and this whole thing
the players I said what's what is for
this isn't for coaches it's for the
players is there the one that's playing
and in creating memories experiences
that'll last a lifetime and the people
you want to share those experience with
as as your mother as your father you
want them sitting in the stands being
proud of and some people just don't
understand what some people have or
don't have you know your definition of
poor may be different than somebody else
definition so you can't generalize or
put disadvantaged people in one category
so why can't they do this hey you should
be able to do this well it depends
people like you said unintended
consequences what we all have that like
this particular parent has a tough you
know in this kid survives because of the
cost of attendance check the greatest
demands the greatest thing ever
is being able to scholarship kids in the
month of June for summer school and give
them concert agendas checks ten months a
year and it has been an unbelievable act
by the n-c-double-a but the determent
happens sometimes once a lifetime for
these kids
and you know you just like to see
parents a lot of parents can afford it
sure but there somebody can't neither
worked out how to monitor how to
legislate it haven't thought through on
that somebody a lot smarter than I kick
than I am can figure that out but I just
something I think that if we can do cost
of attendance checks for kids after all
those years of doing nothing surely we
can figure this out a few more minutes
left with Calvin Sampson Houston head
coach and the cost of the or the the
money that is being brought in by the
tournament was something that was thrown
out when coach Tom Izzo was coaching his
kid really hard in the minds of some a
little too hard for somebody who's not
being paid to be coached in that manner
I wonder what you thought of the Tom
Izzo Aaron Henry a coach and player
sequence all I take thats one of those
deals or if you had seen Tom in practice
the day before that's probably the kid
who gets the most tough love - usually
the kid that you have the best
relationship with off the court is the
one you coach hardest on the court and
that's why they don't that's why they
take it the right way I didn't see the
rest of the game rich I don't know how
the rest of the game played out to that
particular kid but there's no doubt in
my mind he reacted to that the right way
because that's what he expects from Tom
that Tom's personality you know is there
some things that there's their sentences
and words that are taken out of context
and if you had seen the entire story
you'd understand it but tom is
passionate
that's why his team's play the way they
play that's why that kid reacted the way
he reacted what's he went on the court
that if Tom put his arm around them and
and told him it in a different way he
would say ma'am what's wrong with coach
Shawn the coach says Oh does he sit so
when he came at him like Thomas the
coaches oh I know he does that every day
so in the confines of that team I'm sure
they were used to it that's boy tom
coaches and and that's why he's he's a
hall-of-famer so who's a coach was a kid
that in your history of your coaching
that you had to coach the toughest in
that regard well there's always one on
every team the one on this team since
day one has been our senior point guard
a little obviously you know getting kids
to understand the difference in playing
hard versus competing is not easy and
you don't do it by patting them on the
back saying nice try today son sometimes
you have to hold them up hold them
accountable just for their effort and
there's so many different ways to do it
there's about there's coaches a lot
better than I am to do it their way I'm
sure but you know I took this hard and
but they know what they're getting into
sometimes are there no sudden get like
that that night he's been like that his
whole career
the cameras just happened to catch that
one thing but I'm sure he's done that
hundreds and hundreds of time and those
kids understand that they accept it and
they knew that going in
so a couple more questions for you here
before I let you go your celebration
post game against Ohio State is that the
first time you came in with the water
gun is that is that is that a new thing
for for those who might not know I think
this was I think this was a level up
maybe two levels up from a water gun hmm
okay actually before and when I came
from the the media session and came down
the hall
my son kelan and made a target run
earlier that day to get some milk for
his daughter my granddaughter Maisie and
he said was we're in this game tonight
we're gonna be prepared so after we play
Cincinnati on the road and I clinched
the regular season championship for so
they took the orange Gatorade thing that
was full of ice and water and just
doused me I actually thought that was
great
I made sure that one Galen back there
getting back at the old coach were
coaching them so hard but going into the
after we beat Ohio State if we win tell
us that if we win we're gonna be able to
get our licks in first so we went in
there with our super soakers blazing I
was I was getting my licks in before I
got doused and Tennessee fund um hey
look as a Michigan guy beating Ohio
State is cause for celebration
you know I be on you know I kind of
appreciated that what challenge last one
for you here what challenge is Kentucky
present here with Coach Cal you know
what you don't see these teams a lot so
you don't know the intricacies or what
it is they're trying to get to or which
kids they get to identity Trump but
after watching them for two days just
really impressed with with Taos plan for
his team you know there's some coaches
that it's like a a no hit good field
shortstop so he could hit 284 two years
and he'd still be a no hit good field
shortstop no calgis I think the bad
wraps were been a great recruiter and
maybe not as good a coach but this guy
is a really really good
coach is watching that this is this is
as good a coach team as will have played
all year
Hagen's and zero and Johnson the three
perimeter guys PJ Washington Travis Reed
Montgomery inside Richard's they know
what they're doing they're good at
running the hero in and out of those
screens they're big and strong ups front
isn't the best this is the best team
that we have played no disrespect to any
team we played thus far but the best
team will have played this year will be
Kentucky coach appreciate the time
obviously busy time of year really
appreciate it great conversation I hope
to have another one real soon okay you
too that's Kelman Sampson Houston head
coach the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience